hey 42 here when the band's the Arctic
Monkeys formed not a single one of them
could play a musical instrument welcome
to RIF if you wait in a different New
York eatery every day for 12 years you
still wouldn't have visited all the
city's restaurants lizards can't breathe
and walk at the same time coyotes in the
US have learned how traffic lights work
so they can cross the road safely the
world's largest container ship can carry
746 million bananas a quarter of
American couples sleep in separate beds
90% of all jellyfish are smaller than a
human full nail John Montague the 11th
and current Earl of Sandwich runs a
chain of sandwich shops called Earl of
Sandwich drinking wine before a meal
makes you eat 25% more the place where
Hitler killed himself is now a
children's playground Barry Manilow's
number one hit I write the songs wasn't
written by Barry Manilow in 2002 the US
military developed a sandwich that
stayed fresh for three years on the 28th
of June 2009 Stephen Hawking hosted a
party for time travelers from the future
no one's heard of New Zealand has an
official National wizard in wine tasting
a cut pea aroma is a compliment thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2